bonjour et merci d'être en direct avec
nous sur interface alors comment est
perçue chez les forces de l'ordre que
vous représentez la cette création d'un
service des deux policiers victimes de
violences il ya deux points importants
le premier c'est de constater
malheureusement qu'un autre policier des
malades parce qu'une profession société
est très malade et d'en arriver là le
désarroi et la colère que qui s'exprime
dans nos rangs c'est un aveu d'échec on
met trop positif malgré tout puisque
ceux-ci ont créé 6 ministère de
l'intérieur à crissier de plateformes
c'est que on a envie de croire
sa volonté est de soutenir sa police
comme ça a été dit dernièrement je
rappelle également que l'an dernier déjà
une plateforme à l'éviter chef
d'instance sur les suicides dans la
police qui sont en augmentation vous
avez deux fois plus de suicides dans la
police que dans les autres professions a
ressemblé à cette nouvelle plateforme à
quoi est-ce qu'elle va ressembler selon
vous écoutez il faut surtout pas que ce
soit uniquement un centre d'appel pour
le policier et se libérer de ses
angoisses et je pense aussi aux
angoisses des gradins quand on regarde
qu'on est pris pour cible après la
défaite de match où la victoire de match
ces derniers jours on peut imaginer les
enfants qui regardent la fin de match
est peut-être imaginer son père dans un
camion de police and transfer et c'est
donc là se dire la difficulté forte dans
les familles et le policier lui ce
qu'ils attendent bien sûr après s'être
exprimée c'est certainement pas de se se
lâcher et d'être écoutés il faut que
bien sûr on tienne compte de ces a fait
des nombreuses d'appel malheureusement
je crée qui vont qui vont venir pour
qu'on prenne les choses en main et qu'on
qu'on soutienne mais pas uniquement
verbalement notre position de bois aussi
sur un plan juridique nous soutenir
systématiquement lorsqu'on est victime
de violence forte
on doit en fait notre ministère doit
déposer plainte doit se porter partie
civile ça c'est plus important remonte à
être isolés comme nous avons le
sentiment de l'éperon le ministre de
l'intérieur a déclaré le 5 août dernier
vouloir mieux former les policiers en
début de carrière
c'est un problème réel aujourd'hui les
policiers ne sont pas suffisamment
préparés à la violence à laquelle ils
sont aujourd'hui confrontés son terrain
alors déjà on peut souligner
la présence du ministère sur le terrain
et il va à la rencontre des policiers
comme on peut le voir sur ces images et
donc c'est quand même déjà une très
bonne chose conclut il constate par
lui-même que voilà que vous avez des
forces de l'ordre aujourd'hui policiers
gendarmes policiers municipaux qui sont
dévouées qui sont courageux qui ont
envie de travailler au niveau de la
formation pour répondre à votre question
il faut savoir que le recrutement a été
un peu plus importants conséquence ces
dernières années il a fallu aussi
renforcé des services spécialisés comme
les renseignements territoriaux dont
commun que plus elle manque d'effectifs
sur l'autre sur le terrain évidemment
lorsqu'on on recrute on va dire entre
guillemets massivement aidé faut se
donner les moyens de former ça prend du
temps et c'est vrai que là on doit
aujourd'hui regardez aussi les services
spécialisés qui sont existants il ya la
formation dans les écoles mais il ya des
services spécialisés ou des services
pratiques
je pense à mes collègues en 8es et leurs
ergots d'impôts pour tous qui
travaillent la nuit parce que c'est un
dossier que nous avons soutenu depuis de
nombreuses années il ya eu un geste là
aussi c'est pas rien c'est parlant un
premier geste j'espère qu'il y en aura
d'autres
avec une enveloppe de 10 millions
d'euros donc continuons à travailler
pour que le statut du travailleur de
nuit soit reconnu et là ça me prend le
chemin on peut à unité sgp police se
satisfaire de ce premier résultat on va
continuer à travailler parce que nous
rencontrons régulièrement le ministre
qui lui-même semble quand même très à
l'écouté des difficultés qu'on rencontre
et quant aux moyens qui sont mis à
disposition de la police nationale par
l'état est qu'ils sont suffisants à vos
yeux
alors syndicaliste vous dire que c'est
toujours insuffisant il ya eu des
efforts de fait on a beaucoup de retard
vous savez je pense aussi aux policiers
dans le déroulement de sa carrière
imaginez la pression qui s'exerce sur
suran conscience qui ne sait pas comment
il peut être muté à quel moment il va
avancer d'un d'assez grade alors qu'il a
en procession ces examens depuis de
nombreuses années c'est ça aussi c'est
une pression énorme et ça ce sont des
moyens aussi à mettre sur un sur la
table bien sûr qu'on a besoin de moyens
pour fonctionner de véhicules en parfait
état
une protection également au niveau des
délais des moyens qu'on puisse
travailler en toute sécurité
mais on doit aussi regarder le sas peu
que l'on se donne à cette carrière de
policier
on n'est pas très bien payé si après
avoir réussi un examen doit attendre dix
ans pour passer au grade supérieur
dans l'incertitude de mutation c'est
très difficile pour la famille pour que
le policier déjà puisse travailler
sereinement et si ce sens soutenu
si ce sera à peu près sereine parce
qu'on a une mission difficile
bien que très exposées vient des gens
pour affronter certaines difficultés que
nous rencontrons au quotidien c'est je
vous rappelle que n'intervienne toutes
les 8 9 secondes en france il ya très
peu de dégâts
deux policiers gardant le travail vous
savez 10000 de policiers dix mille
policiers qui sont blessés tous les ans
d'un service c'est énorme je vous parle
pas des problèmes psychologiques qu'on
importe parce que le sujet tabou en bas
m'a rencontré des médecins des
psychiatres et puis qui on ne parlera
pas autour de soi il faut se libérer de
ça il faut qu'on nous aide justement à
nous libérer et peut-être nous nous
accompagner dans notre profession dans
une volonté de nous garder longtemps
dans cette profession parce que on parle
de démission c'est pas normal dans cette
police on puisse parler de démission
parce qu'on arrivera ce que ce métier
avec avec force avec amour pour le
métier avec passion
merci beaucoup d'avoir agi sur notre
antenne 1 ce matin renault à bartocetti
je rappelle que vous êtes secrétaire au
sud du syndicat unité sgp police